you j'espère que vous allez bien daschle
et ne m'a contacté pour faire une vidéo
sur la sécurité
et ça m'a fait penser à une pote qui m'a
dit il ya quelques temps je ne sais pas
comment me protéger en termes de
sécurité informatique
ça va être une vidéo sur l'éducation
sexuelle et elle m'a dit chez parce
qu'il faut que je fasse je sais pas par
où commencer et 7,9
ce qui est intéressant c'est qu'elle a
un post it sur sa webcam et ça m'a donné
une idée de vidéos il ya beaucoup de
gens qui mettent un post it sur la
webcam
je trouve ça hyper intéressant à
observer ce qui est intéressant c'est
que les gens qui font ça souvent c'est
pas des psycho rigide de la sécurité ni
même de la vie privée ils ont un compte
facebook qu'ils utilisent tous connectés
à plein de trucs
ils n'ont pas de vpn quand ils sont à
l'aéroport ou au café et qui utilise le
wi fi
ils ont des mots de passe bidon donc
c'est chelou quoi pourquoi en fait
pourquoi mettre un post it sur la webcam
et ben c'est simple c'est la raison
c'est parce que c'est simple en fait
c'est pas seulement simple à faire c'est
à dire mettre un post it sur une caméra
c'est que c'est simple à comprendre quoi
il ya une caméra elle me films
potentiellement des gens pourraient se
connecter à cette caméra pour me voir
donc si je mets un truc sur cette caméra
pas les gens peuvent plus me voir les
paires simple c'est des choses simples
que les gens applique et donc qui marche
parce que la promesse de la technologie
c'est de nous simplifier la vie
dès qu'on va faire quelque chose en
terme de technologie qui va racheter des
contraintes etc
ça marche pas les gens ne font pas sauf
que ça crée des opportunités du coup
pour se faire attaquer et on n'aime pas
se faire attaquer cette vidéo je l'avais
la plus simple possible
et idéalement elle est tellement simple
vous pouvez l'envoyer à vos parents pour
qu'ils puissent se protéger efficacement
et c'est la seule fois je vous souhaite
d'avoir des parents divorcés
ça prend plus de vue là lorsque j'ai
enfin faire le montage et on a
l'impression que je pense que tous les
parents sont
sont tombés quoi c'est pas du tout c'est
pas du tout ce que je veux c'est juste
qu'on va pas se mentir on l'a tous vu
que pour certains parents le monde
informatique est un peu plus compliqué
si vous êtes parent et que vous sentez
pas du tout concerné par ça temps mais
bon vous c'est que vous n'êtes pas
concerné par ça du coup je vais dire des
choses qui vont paraître évidente pour
certains et ben du coup ce n'est pas à
vous que je m'adresse
c'est aux autres donc pour ce soit le
plus simple possible on va avoir trois
erreurs basiques et leurs solutions et
donc c'est à partir de ce thème code que
vous pouvez envoyer vos parents d'abord
les mots de passe beaucoup de sites nous
demande de créer un compte et donc de
mettre notre adresse mail avec un mot de
passe
alors il ya deux problèmes qu'on veut
contrer avec les mots de passe 1 les
pirates qui vont avec des logiciels
pouvoir tester plein de combinaisons
possibles et retrouver votre mot de
passe et 2 les pirates qui peuvent à
quai un site internet avec toutes ces
données et donc récupérer des bases de
d'identifiants et de mots de passe et
ensuite les revendre sur le dark est la
conséquence de ça c'est que quelqu'un de
malveillant pourrait racheter cette base
de données et si vous avez le même mot
de passe sur d'autres sites
eh ben on peut très facilement se
connecter à tous vos comptes en fait
tous les comptes qui utilise ce mot de
passe en tout cas déjà pour le premier
problème c'est à dire éviter de se faire
forcer son mot de passe
il faut changer la conception de mot de
passe
ne pensez plus mot de passe pensez
phrase de passe c'est à dire ne pensait
pas genre tomates 25,06 penser je vais
amener trois tomates chez ma grand-mère
prince crémation avec le 3 en chiffres
c'est beaucoup plus difficile à forcer
un il ya beaucoup plus de caractère et à
la ponctuation il ya des espaces et des
majuscules et les chiffres pour vous
c'est facile à retenir
en tout cas tout aussi facile que
tomates 25,06 j'imagine et donc vu que
c'est très long c'est très difficile a
forcé maintenant pour éviter le problème
il faut surtout éviter le fait
d'utiliser le même mot de passe partout
mais en même temps c'est humain quoi
enfin on est sûr sollicité il faut créer
des comptes partout en france on peut
pas retenir autant de mots de passe
différents - pour vous dirait un moment
je m'étais fait un algorithme dans ma
tête en fonction du nom du site et de
souvenirs personnels et de chiffres etc
je crée un mot de passe unique pour le
site est bien au bout d'un moment j'ai
lâché la faire quoi sert que les sites
qui m'importait peu je m'étais le même
mot de passe grave erreur
heureusement il ya ce qu'on appelle des
gestionnaire de mots de passe est l'un
d'eux daschle et sponsorise cette vidéo
à titre personnel j'utilise d'acheter in
depuis plus d'un an maintenant donc bien
avant qu'il me contacte pour faire cette
vidéo et j'en suis très satisfait en
gros quand je me connecte à un site
d'acheter une retient mon mot de passe
et me propose de le remplir
automatiquement
et quand j'ai créé un nouveau compte
daschle et ne propose de générer un mot
de passe hyper sécurisé beaucoup plus
sécurisée que ce que j'aurais fait
beaucoup plus sécurisée que j'ai ramené
trois tomates chez ma grand-mère prince
la mission qui est déjà pas mal
alors moi j'avoue les gestionnaire de
mots de passe j'ai eu beaucoup de temps
à y aller parce que je me disais c'est
pire en fait puisque si quelqu'un ac
le gestionnaire de mots de passe en fait
il a tous mes mots de passe quoi donc
c'est pire et en fait ça c'est pas
possible parce que d'acheter in stock
aucun mot de passe sur leurs serveurs
tout ce qu'ils ont c'est cryptée est en
fait la clé de cryptage ce qui permet de
décrypter tout ce qu'ils ont
c'est votre mot de passe m ils appellent
ça un mot de passe maître c'est le mot
de passe que vous utilisez pour vous
connecter à dachau en fait qui lui est
stocké nulle part donc j'ai une bonne
passe phrase pour me connecter hadash
line tellement complexe que ça arrive
assez fréquemment que bas que je songe
alors à la retaper une deuxième fois
parce que ça peut marcher et d'ailleurs
sur sur mac avec le le truc détecteur
d'empreintes digitales
on peut aussi déverrouiller d'acheter
une juste avec l'empreinte digitale ce
qui est très pratique
j'imagine que sur d'autres ordinateurs
qu'avec des lecteurs d'empreintes
digitales ça le fait aussi j'en sais
rien je sais pas je peux je vous parle
de mon expérience sur mac d'ailleurs sur
les autres appareils sur lesquels
j'utilise c'est à dire l'iphone et
l'ipad
ça fonctionne aussi avec le fait ça il
dit celle qui reconnaît mon visage et
donc du coup il peut déverrouiller comme
ça j'ai pas obligés de retaper mapas
phrase qui est actuellement beaucoup
trop longue vous avez d'autres
fonctionnalités par exemple à une
fonctionnalité qui vous dit votre nombre
de mots de passe qui sont identiques qui
du coup vous incite à les changer
vous voyez moi il me reste quand même
pas mal qui sont identiques et ensuite
ils ont aussi un système de veille qui
font qu'ils surveillent en fait le dark
net pour voir si vous avez des mots de
passe des identifiants qui ont fuité et
auquel cas il faudra les changer le pays
de possibles donc voilà pour vos parents
vos grands parents vouloir installer un
gestionnaire de mots de passe
si possible d'acheter ligne pour faire
plaisir à votre créateur préféré vous
c'est ep le truc les extensions dans les
navigateurs et c'est pour que quand il
se connecte paf ça se fasse
automatiquement ou en tout cas en 2
clics
et voila quoi le tour est joué et au
passage ils peuvent aussi mettre leur
carte de crédit leur adresse pour pré
remplir les champs quand il ya besoin
d'eux et d'acheter il intègre aussi un
vpn
quand il ya besoin de l'activé wes
inclus et si vous voulez essayer
d'acheter une gratos pas de soucis vous
avez sûr d'acheter une pointe comme
slash cyrus north et vous vous laissez
guider maintenant si jamais vous ne
voulez pas d'application hockey et que
vous rejetez cette société je comprends
tout à fait mais pays quand même un
gestionnaire de mots de passe j'en sais
rien apprenez incarnait un truc mettait
le sou vous travaillez quand vous
coucher mais est il ya un gestionnaire
de mots de passe
c'est pas possible en fait on n'est pas
fait pour retenir autant de mots de
passe différents
enfin on pourrait le faire et une époque
on retenait les répertoires avec tous
les numéros de téléphone voilà est-ce
qu'on en a envie
non personne n'a envie de faire ça la
seule personne que je connais qui aurait
peut-être envie de faire ça c'est fabien
olicard entre quelques décimales de pi
oui tu viens me dire prendre t1 chiffre
depuis depuis un élément très important
quand on parle de mot de passe
activer la double authentification c'est
ce truc qui envoie un sms où vous devez
rentrer un code en plus du mot de passe
etc et donc activer le chez vos parents
vos grands parents etc
c'est super important et ça permet de
sécuriser beaucoup plus votre compte
vous n'êtes pas obligé de le faire pour
tous mais faites le pour et le contre
important quoi ensuite
le phishing la faille exploitée par les
pirates lors des attaques
très souvent c'est le comportement
humain en fait vous savez c'est comme
quand vous êtes en vacances ou vous
promener et puis vous rencontrez un gars
est vraiment genre 5000 plus tard vous
avez acheté un bracelet 40 balles ça
vous et gérard créée voilà moi ça m'est
déjà arrivé eh bien là c'est pareil mais
sur le web il ya quelques semaines j'ai
reçu un sms de la poste enfin je croyais
que c'était la poste et sa 10
la chose suivante nous avons essayé de
livrer votre colis bla bla bla bla bla
mais il n'y a aucun affranchissement
veuillez suivre les instructions
suivantes
bîmes un lien je clique sur le lien déjà
erreur erreur monumentale ne pas faire
ça c'est un lien que je connais pas je
devrai d'abord le prendre et le coller
dans virus total.com ou url scan point i
o qui vont me dire si le site qu'il ya
derrière et malicieux sens que moi même
je prenne le risque d'y aller très
important
donc j'arrive sur le site de la poste
ils me disent voilà votre colis n'est
pas franchie il faut la franchir pour le
recevoir
ça coûte à peu près 2 euros et là je
sais pas ce qui se passe j'ai un léger
doute
je suis sur mobile donc on voit pas
l'adresse du site tout de suite mais je
regarde l'adresse du site et je vois
qu'on n'est pas du tout sur la poste en
fait qu'est-ce que c'est du phishing
cercle a potentiellement on m'aurait
pris 2 euros on aurait peut-être même
pris mes coordonnées bancaires etc
et vu que c'est fait à large échelle à 2
euros par ci deux euros par là ils
peuvent se faire beaucoup beaucoup
d'argent et il arrive exactement la même
chose à un pote qui lui pour le coup
c'est fait avoir malheureusement donc
alors que c'est quelqu'un qui passe
beaucoup de temps sur internet qui est
au fait de tout sexe et a donc vraiment
mon est faillible
c'est vraiment la tâche la plus courante
l' attaque classique vous recevez un sms
qui vous demandent de l'argent sur un
truc on vous demande de vous reconnecter
à 1,6 du genre vous avez été déconnecté
de facebook il faut vous reconnecter
bref tout un tas de choses à chaque fois
que vous devez de rentrer un mot de
passe rentrée des informations paiement
ce genre de choses
vérifiez bien le nom du site sur lequel
vous êtes avec l'adresse et si vous avez
un doute vous pouvez copier ce site dans
virustotal ou url scan joue mais les
liens en descriptions et si vous avez
des stein du coup il vous proposera pas
de rentrer votre mot de passe
car il reconnaît que vous n'êtes pas sur
le site habituel voilà mais dans tous
les cas restez aux aguets
dernier point les mises à jour mon
dernier conseil qui s'adresse à vos
parents c'est vraiment un conseil de
parents faites vos mises à jour c'est
très simple là aussi pour le coup et en
fait ça vous permet d'être beaucoup plus
sécurisée puisque les constructeurs et
développeurs réparé les failles de
sécurité qui sont trouvés voilà c'est
tout c'était vraiment le conseil mise à
jour est très simple juste fait les
mises à jour donc voilà c'est important
pour moi de faire une vidéo simple sur
ce sujet qui répond à cette question
simple qui et comment se protéger a
utilisé un gestionnaire de passe ou en
tout cas à faire gaffe à ces mots de
passe
et activer la double authentification 2
être vigilant par rapport au phishing et
utiliser les sites que je vous mets en
descriptions sur virustotal élus et les
scans etc et 3 faire ces mises à jour
tout ça c'est aussi simple qu'un post it
sur webcam le plus complexe et peut-elle
le gestionnaire de mots de passe
et encore une fois qu'il est installé
ciao j'espère que cette vidéo vous
aurait aidé vous ou vos proches
encore merci à dachau lane d'avoir
sponsorisé cette vidéo encore une fois
vous pouvez essayer gratuitement
d'acheter in sur votre premier appareil
en allant sur d'acheter in.com slash
cyrus north et si vous voulez passer à
la version premium vous avez 50 % de
réduction avec le code promo cyrus torse
voilà faites vous plaisir merci à justin
de la chaîne le point sécu qui m'a
permis de faire une ou deux
vérifications et donc de ne pas dire
totalement n'importe quoi voilà vous
embrasse très fort je fais de gros
bisous on se revoit la semaine prochaine
dimanche à 10h30 love peace ciao